I grew up in Riverside California I have
two brothers and three sisters my mom
would take me out in the country
sometimes and just dropped me off and I
just go explore my fourth-grade teacher
told me I'm not supposed to go off in
the mountains and ski and get pinecones
and fish your kind of people don't do
that but being out in the parks and
River bottoms in the mountain areas
where I lived I was able to see some of
the wild birds fly and catch rabbits and
chase each other and raise young I
didn't really understand what it was but
I knew I didn't want to have some type
of a relationship with the birds
some friends of mine found this bird out
in the street there was a young right
doha not even ready to fly if they knew
that I was into bird so they brought it
to me so I raised this bird one of my
friends brought home a falconry book I
tried to read it but I really didn't
understand it because it was really
in-depth but I would just look at the
pictures
try to put as much as I could together I
knew that falconers put bells on their
birds and so I would go up in the attic
and raid my mom's Christmas decorations
and put Christmas bells on my Birds legs
thinking that was a part of the falconry
equipment you know I'm walking around
with a garden glove I have this hawk on
my fist and I had no idea what I was
doing but I'm practicing falconry in the
city
[Music]
falconry is not a sport it's not an art
it's a way of life falconry was started
before we had guns that was a way that
people put food on the table
my Birds to me we're just partners
it's my responsibility to provide them
with the opportunity to go out and hunt
[Music]
you trying to orchestrate the perfect
flight the enjoyment I get out of it is
watching and that's the relationship
falconers and falcons have we don't fly
our birds with strings on them anything
sometimes they do fly away and you have
to start over every day you get your
bird back is a successful day on my
Birds Hut they're pretty serious they're
designed for speed the pointed wings you
know how their feathers are shaped and
long toes and that little notch in their
nose cuts the air and allows them to
breathe while they come down and strike
their prey with force and when they're
coming to approach their game you hear
it before you see it through that air
make contact this like a jab punch the
Falcon strikes it in days is it shape
for their beaks or designed to snap the
vertebrae kill them instantly
Raptors and hawks live really hard lives
and to have a relationship with a wild
animal knowing that that wild animal
accepts you as a partner and as a friend
is the blessing that bird doesn't care
what color I am that bird doesn't care
what kind of car I Drive that bird
doesn't care you know where I sleep at
night and if I make that bird understand
that I want to be its partner and given
an opportunity to live and fly and have
relationship with me I can apply that to
with you or anybody else the day that I
release my bird back out to the wild I
know that bird is gonna survive I know
that bird is gonna go out and probably
get a mate and produce other birds in
the wild and I was a part of it I look
at those mountains of the Sierras and
the whites and sometimes I really
actually pinch myself like wow I'm
really here
I practice Falcon me with the people in
Europe I practice walking with the
people in the Middle East
South Africa I'm not rich but I live a
pretty good life I never even thought
that I would make a living and traveling
the world and consulting on different
techniques with different falconers and
I want to actually try to give back and
share some of my experiences if I can
help other foreigners and non falconers
I understand what falconry is doing you
know if I can keep a kid from becoming a
drug addict and if I can help a kid stay
in school that's the peak other than
catching a prairie chicken with my
Falcons but yeah that would be my
perfect flight
[Music]